function is something that's written in
this notation here such as f of X equals
like 3x minus 1 and what this represents
is that whatever is in the parentheses
you're going to put in place of X on the
right side of the equation so like for
example if we want to find out what f of
5 is we would replace X with 5 so we'd
have 3 times 5 minus 1
that'd be 15 minus 1 which is 14 so
you're probably familiar with that
already but when you're working with a
graph it's the same concept whatever is
in the parentheses is going to be your x
value or your input and then whatever
comes out that's going to be your Y
value so for example if we're doing
number one here we say well what's F of
G of 2 we start on the inside of the
parenthesis G of 2 we go to our G
function we realize that when the x
value is 2 so let's see X is 1/2 all
right this is the x-axis we go up to the
graph we can see that the Y value is 1
so this is actually equal to 1 right
here and now we work from the inside out
we'd say well okay what's F of 1 we go
to our half function here we say when X
is 1 we go up to the graph you can see
that the Y value is equal to 2 and
that's our final solution so basically
start from the inside and work your way
out let's do another example so for
example 2 here we have G of f of 2 so we
start on the inside we go to our F
function okay we say when X is equal to
2 1 2 we go up to the graph we can see
that the Y value is 1 2 3 ok so f of 2
is actually equal to 3 so now we have to
figure out what's G of 3 so we go to our
G function we say when X is 3 we go 1 2
3 on the x-axis we go up to the graph
the Y value is equal to 1 so this whole
quantity here G of f of 2 is equal to 1
ok two more examples see if you can do
these if you want go ahead and pause the
video number three we've got G of F of
one so same thing we start on the inside
we say go to our F function when x
equals one we go up to the graph we can
see that the Y value is equal to 2 so
this whole quantity is 2 then we go over
to the G function when x equals 2 we're
going right to we go up to the graph and
you can see that
the Y value is 1 so when you think of f
of X or G of X let's think of that as
the y-coordinate whatever is in the
parentheses think of that as the
x-coordinate ok last example see if you
can do this one F of G of 3 so here
we're going to go over to the G function
1 2 3 we go up to the graph we can see
that the Y value is 1 so this is 1 now
we just have to find out what's F of 1
well when X is 1 we go up to the graph
you can see that the y value is equal to
2 and you've got it so if you want to
see additional examples working with
composition of functions just doing the
algebraic part not working with the
graph check out the video I did right
there
and I'll see you over in that video